pour commencer
j'aimerais définir deux notions au coeur
de mon intervention
celle de la culture et celle de la
réussite
google définit la culture comme
l'ensemble des aspects intellectuels et
artistiques d'une civilisation
à l'école de la république on nous
apprend qu'il existe également d'autres
formes de culture propre à chaque
entreprise chaque métier chaque
institution
et même chaque famille
quant à la réussite elle se traduit par
un succès ou l'atteinte d'un objectif
elle est synonyme de victoire et de
réalisation
maintenant j'ai une question à vous
poser combien parmi vous êtes des
enfants d'immigrés lever la main si
c'est votre cas
ok lever bien haut parce que je suis
bien
[Rires]
d'accord on est au moins je dirais un
tiers
et bien cela fera autant de personnes
qui se reconnaîtront certainement dans
mon vécu mais même sans être enfants
d'immigrés je pense que vous vous
reconnaîtrez facilement
et que vous vous identifierez à la
pression qui repose sur les épaules de
la jeunesse l'impératif de réussite
dans ma culture congolaise réussir c'est
faire la fierté des siens
mon grand père julien boukambou était un
syndicaliste qui s'est battu pour la
liberté de son peuple et de ses
descendants en militant fermement pour
l'indépendance du congo brazzaville
mon père est tout aussi passionné par
l'avenir de son pays quand il est arrivé
en france c'était pour acquérir des
compétences qui lui permettrait de se
remettre au service de sa nation
d'origine et c'est pour ça qu'il est
devenu docteur en économie
vous l'aurez compris dans ma famille
comme dans ma culture la réussite est un
enjeu collectif et c'est pour ça que
pour moi congolaise échoué n'était pas
une option
vous imaginez donc bien que dès ma
naissance et même bien avant mon père
avait déjà planifié
après des études brillantes de la
maternelle au lycée dans un
établissement privé je serai sélectionné
pour poursuivre mon cursus scolaire au
sein d'une classe préparatoire 2
préférence appartenant au top 10 du
classement national après quoi je
rejoindrai les rangs d'une grande école
de commerce avant d'entrer dans une
certaine école nationale
d'administration pour finir au mieux
présidente du monde
au pire ministre des affaires étrangères
rien que ça
dès mon plus jeune âge j'ai appris à
travailler dur pour ne pas décevoir les
autres et à suivre la voie que l'on
m'avait tracé
malheureusement ou heureusement si je me
trouve devant vous aujourd'hui c'est que
tout ne s'est pas totalement déroulé
comme prévu pour mon papa pardon pour
moi
c'est lorsque j'ai validé non sans
difficulté ma première année en classe
préparatoire que les choses ont commencé
à se compliquer on m'a dit que si
j'étais incapable de tenir une seconde
année c'est parce que j'étais trop bête
il faut savoir qu'en france il existe
une grande disparité dans la
représentation des enfants d'immigrés et
les enfants dits de natifs au sein de
filières d'élite
moi j'avais remporté ma place au sein de
cette minorité en intégrant le lycée
carnot mais malgré tous mes efforts je
n'étais pas parvenu à me montrer à la
hauteur de cette place d'exception
et c'était difficile pour la bonne élève
que j'avais toujours été car il
s'agissait là de ma toute première
rencontre avec l'échec un échec cuisant
douloureux
et surtout honte
c'est lors de cette première rencontre
avec l'échec que j'ai appris qu'en
france
la réussite équivalent et à une absence
totale de faux pas
c'est lors de cette première rencontre
que j'ai appris qu ici
l'échec était une horrible bête noire
que celle les faibles s'accorder le luxe
de rencontrer
et c'est lors de cette première
expérience que j'ai eu l'impression
de décevoir ma famille et de déshonorer
mais de culture
j'ai donc d'abord refusé d'écouter ce
que l'échec avait à me dire
mais vous savez je suis croyante et que
vous croyez en dieu en l'univers en une
force supérieure ou tout simplement la
vie il se peut que vous expérimente y
ait un proverbe qui dit ceci
la vie est un excellent professeur tant
que vous ne prenez pas les leçons elle
se répète
c'est peut-être la raison pour laquelle
les chèques et moi nous sommes retrouvés
quatre ans plus tard
j'étais désormais diplômés de licence
l'une en commerce international et
l'autre en ressources humaines pas mal
pour quelqu'un qu'on avait dix bêtes
seulement voilà j'avais beau candidater
pour qu'une entreprise me sélectionne et
me permettent de poursuivre mon master
en alternance rien ne se produisait je
ne recevaient aucune réponse favorable
et je me rendais compte que sur le
marché du travail
personne ou presque ne voulait de moi
d'autre part je me surprenais à ne faire
preuve d'aucune combativité dans mes
recherches
travailler me paraissait pénible et
malgré toutes mes bonnes intentions je
n'arrive tout simplement pas à être ou
faire comme les autres
j'avais l'impression que suivre le
chemin classique des études puis du cdi
ce n'était pas fait pour moi
alors était ce mon manque d'expérience
une absence de connaissance ou de
compétences ou même la couleur de ma
peau qui me discriminés
et s on appréhension du monde du travail
un manque de motivation ou tout
simplement de la paresse
aujourd'hui je peux vous répondre avec
assurance que la réponse est non
le problème était que je ne trouvais pas
ma voix
je savais qu'il fallait que je persévère
mais je ne savais pas encore dans quoi
une chose est sûre en revanche
mon dieu
je suis un peu un peu trop sûre de moi
non une chose est sûr en revanche
c'est que je ne me retrouvais absolument
pas dans la culture française de
l'entreprise
ce rapport presque abusif à la
hiérarchie ce mépris de la jeunesse
cette obsession pour le présentéisme
étaient des éléments que jusqu'ici j'ai
vraiment du mal à concevoir
puis je me suis dit que dans cette quête
mais de culture avait peut-être été des
handicaps
parce qu'elle m'avait appris qu en tant
qu enfant je n'aurais jamais droit au
chapitre de ma propre carrière
qu'en tant que congolaise je devrai
justifier ma présence sur le territoire
français en performant constamment dans
mes études
qu'en tant que jeune
je mettrais du temps à trouver ma place
sur le marché du travail et qu'en tant
que femme je devrais redoubler d'efforts
pour prouver que je mérite la
considération à laquelle je prétends
toutes ces croyances sont des croyances
héritées de mes deux cultures mais des
croyances limitantes et certainement les
raisons pour lesquelles j'avais du mal à
m'orienter
pour trouver ma voie j'allais devoir en
faire abstraction
j'ai donc réalisé un test de
personnalité que peut-être beaucoup
d'entre vous connaissent
et ce test m'a révélé que j'étais une
diplomate à mi chemin entre la
personnalité charismatique
et optimiste
et deux des éléments qui caractérisent
le plus ce type de personnalité sont
leurs besoins de liberté et leur
créativité
les environnements leur imposant trop de
contraintes ont tendance à les empêcher
de performer cqfd
hélas illuminations j'allais devenir mon
propre patron
sauf que
une fois devenu freelance je n'étais
toujours pas plus libres parce que je ne
mettais toujours pas libéré de ses
croyances limitantes et que je continue
de vivre pour l'acceptation des autres
je pensais avoir soigné mon rapport à
l'échec en devenant entrepreneurs mais
en réalité j'avais juste transféré mon
besoin d'être validé par mes deux
cultures d'origine un besoin d'être
validé par une culture d'entreprise
or il existe en sciences sociales et
psychologiques
un concept qui s'appelle la prophétie
auto réalisatrice
et ce concept observe que nos croyances
forge nous réalité
comme le disait si bien job dans la
bible ce que je crains c'est ce qui
m'arrive et c'est ce que j'ai
expérimenté
j'avais peur d'échouer et l'échec ou
plutôt la peur attirer les chèques
et comme j'associe l'échec au rejet je
vivais très mal le fait de ne pas
répondre aux standards d'une part du
salariat et d'une autre de
l'entrepreneuriat
il m'aura fallu trois rencontres
supplémentaires avec lui pas de job les
gênes
2 matérialiser en emploi que je n'ai su
garder et la dernière en un terrible
burn out en tant que freelance pour que
j'accepte enfin de m'asseoir et
d'écouter ce que les chèques avaient à
m'apprendre au sujet de la réussite
est là
j'ai appris qu'il était bon de
persévérer mais pour les bonnes raisons
jusqu alors j'avais fait preuve de
résilience mais dans la mauvaise
direction
j'ai compris que pour trouver ma voie
j'avais besoin de briser le moule des
deux cultures qui m'avait forget et
paradoxalement je me suis aperçu que
suivre ma voie était une forme d'hommage
à ma culture familiale d'indépendance
parce qu'après tout mon grand père était
un révolutionnaire et mon père un
consultant indépendant aussi
j'ai appris à puiser dans tout ce que
j'avais acquis en chemin pour rebondir
on amour pour la culture populaire afro
américaines par exemple m'a montré que
je devrais peut-être repenser l'échec de
la même manière dont le pense les
entrepreneurs que j'admire outre
atlantique c'est à dire une fierté un
tremplin quelque chose à faire valoir
sur mon cv
l'un des exemples les plus inspirants
pour moi est celui de michael jordan
qui est l'un des si ce n'est pas le plus
grand basketteur de l'histoire
et lui même a déclaré
je cite j'ai échoué encore et encore et
encore et c'est pourquoi je réussis
et là j'ai eu un déclic
parce que si même les plus grands
expérimenté l'échec à un moment ou un
autre de leur carrière qui était pour ne
pas l'expérimenté
tous ces éléments m'ont permis de
redéfinir ma vision et ma définition de
l'échec et de la réussite
et c'est cette vision qui me permet de
me tenir devant vous aujourd'hui est de
vous dire que peu importe votre culture
la réussite c'est ce qui se produit
lorsque l'on a plus peur d'échouer
parce que si vous pensiez y échapper
détrompez vous je vous le dis ça
n'arrivera pas
vous rencontrerez certainement l'échec à
plusieurs reprises et peut-être même dès
la sortie de cette école
est d'ailleurs je vous le souhaite parce
que les progrès que vous ferez en
échouant seront bien plus gratifiant que
le petit confort de la perfection
donc si vous échouez demain ce n'est pas
grave
réessayez
persévérer en restant indulgent avec
vous même et je peux vous garantir que
c'est avec cette persévérance
bienveillante qu'à votre tour vous aussi
vous réussirez merci
[Applaudissements]